Mark showed me this picture of all the
comments that have hit the earth I look
and I go wow that's a lot of comments
and then on the bottom of the picture
goes since 1994. yeah yeah I thought
this was
ever hit it Rogan said this as well to
me he's like yeah we're in a shooting
gallery cosmetry and it's better we
don't think about things like this by
the way it's better for the average
person because I don't recycle as it is
now but if you told me it's possible
that next year we're gonna get hit by
some big I'm not recycling ever I'm
not gonna do a single good thing for the
environment like thinking that like
these political arguments we have like
how many genders are there I have a
million who gives a yeah yeah